[Music]
in poor baby news oh oh man I thought
we're gonna talk about like low-income
babies this is sad one we'll see about
that yeah right David then we're gonna
do it buddy
submitted by me G from the Philippines
p9p now is fun for the Philippines yeah
music from the Philippines but I like
Philippines it'll might be not a father
refused to call nine-one-one as his 8
year old son was dying of a meth
overdose oh my god how did that happen
he got into his dad's I like to hear you
turn this around it I told my ass will
tighten up all the way did you need to
cry I was helping you pass next one
right you always try to make things a
little bit easier to kind of consume but
this one is hard we just got to be real
with like serious I'll come out with the
job if I can but this one's hard I'm
gonna tell real bomb one to end that
he'll sleep I do it now this one really
close to home for me because the way
they described this little boy like he
likes everything that Isaac likes right
now with someone and he also looks like
the kid from Coco Oh a white version
yeah okay let me ask you this did he get
into his daddy's meth stash all right
let's do it let's do it come on break my
heart okay this little kid his name was
Curtis
the third he woke up his father Curtis
the second in the middle of the night
saying that he was really hungry this is
in Indiana by the way okay I heard
there's a lot of meth in Ohio Indiana
yeah so then the father told his son
that there was no food and you've just
ended up going back to sleep and so the
little boy Jonah sucks really hungry
he found his father's meth that had been
left on a clear glass plate in the
kitchen and the cops are saying that the
brownish crystal like substance on the
plate could have been mistaken for
cereal crumbs that's whole [ __ ]
hungry he was yeah
so imagine his life my god this meth
users he's pretty wasteful - you don't
just [ __ ] don't a [ __ ] on the floor
like that well maybe he'll as high as
[ __ ] my glass plate oh I fell on the
floor or something no in the kitchen in
the kitchen so what do meth unlike a
nice plate yeah like what was it serves
it to himself is like for me yeah yeah
thank you
he's like the presentation of the map
he's like people get into the
presentation um yeah yeah talk about the
experience in the environment all the
pipe and everything in like time to
smoke is that my real dream is opening a
meth restaurant I know that's a distant
dream
probably casual it too because they
didn't have electricity in the house oh
my don't have electricity dude this is
like some legit stuff you see on
Breaking Bad holy ah I put that stuff
back kid that little boy right exactly
what he was after dude this is like [ __ ]
so I thought that [ __ ] was all made up
but that stuff is real man do they live
in our RV they say a house it's a house
with no electricity so yep this hungry
ass kid he thought these brown crystals
were cereal crumbs and just starts
eating em in the middle of the night and
then so later on the dad wakes up and he
saw that his son was quote not acting
right and then that he was twitching and
bouncing his face off the floor the hell
yeah some good [ __ ] awesome
the child would grab and scratch his own
face and that he was burning up hot oh
my god he started having seizures and he
vomited and that he became stiff like
super stiff and that his lips turned
blue for four [ __ ] hours this father
knew that his son needed medical
attention and refused people like well
cuz he didn't want to get in trouble
dipper your son's about that's not how
meth heads think yeah true
there you go I don't want the cockpit
put me away and the government to
[ __ ] know what I'm thinking you know
so they'd rather have their [ __ ] kid
just maybe I'll let them wait it out
yeah then apparently that was this
friend I came over a woman and she saw
the kid and started calling 911 this dad
he told her to stop and he pulled out a
gun on her and said like I'm gonna kill
all three of us if you call the cops I'm
not going back to prison and then he
ended up going to his parents house with
the kid oh my and then the parents tried
calling I don't want same thing he
refused violently they mentioned the gun
on the parents but they didn't everyone
line up in a very straight line please I
got one bullet because he couldn't
afford a whole magazine that's like
cleaning everything in his no no I'm
saying cuz he's if he's gonna you're
gonna hold stick everyone up everyone
stay in different places oh no kid
well maybe you only uh offends uh human
thoughts
he didn't register as a sex offender so
he was additionally charged with failure
to register that's why he really doesn't
want to go to jail yeah well hug this
girl thanks for this one TIFF this is
really fun I told you guys but it was
heavily submitted like a lot of our
viewers wanted to see us talk about the
funny thing boy so uh how did he get
caught because they finally once the dad
left the parents house and the parents
called the cops and the cops took the
kid to the hospital and that's when that
kid oh that's so sad I wonder if the
moms like drugged out - were just gone
not around mom's not there yeah that's
some sad ass [ __ ] man it was just hungry
thank God my parents weren't into drugs
is he and like chucky cheese or
something at least he got the Chucky
Cheese birthday yeah what the [ __ ] he's
going back to jail so he would never go
back
that's a flamboyant a shirt dude how
many [ __ ] doubloons any buy that for
how did this [ __ ] even like get a girl
pregnant I don't know but then it was
once the cops finally got a hold of them
and then the kid was sent to the
hospital this dude was telling
investigators that he didn't think his
son ingested the meth because it was
still there when they left the house and
that the child might have gotten into
some chemicals in the bathroom and
that's what was happening oh yeah what a
selfish [ __ ] all he was caring about was
him not going back to jail
and he had enough time to go back in
time and buy that t-shirt that's [ __ ]
crazy dude puffy a shirt that's wild a
[ __ ] gay pirate donated that [ __ ] to
him like like back in the day or
something he you got arrested in that
shirt yeah before you think bill Adele I
got to put on my father set and he asked
to go in there and take his [ __ ]
parts can we go back to that picture
that [ __ ] is so bright - like if he's
trying to get away from people up in
that shirt I'm gonna kill all three of
us that's not my color
I think I'd go with a more white or
maybe even like beige but that one he
literally walked it to his stories that
can I get a shirt that's the color of a
dragon fruit I'm looking for something
raspberry and then with the Bell he just
looks like a really good hair stylist
like a gay hairstyle yeah do you work in
West
I would yeah it looks like the kinda
that would burn it cuz he wants to be
like crazy he also looks like a
substitute teacher
I didn't even picture this though like
the kid is well put together I pictured
like something from the Great Depression
you know like like you know those
black-and-white pictures of like super
dirt-poor and [ __ ] it's like that movie
old brother [ __ ] where art thou uh
you know I'm surprised this kid manatee
hey yeah yeah in his obituary they said
that you enjoyed riding his bike
watching Spongebob in Minecraft of
Tourelles playing with nerf guns and
playing video games
poor little guy waiting for that joke
Steve [ __ ] man this one's tough David
say you had a job I'm waiting for David
Joe I said I said I would take the
challenge and so instead I started
making fun of his shirt you [ __ ] UFC
got me a ticket girl we can reverse burn
I know yeah you too Steve you could go
[ __ ] yourself with him to anything
sounds better than this [ __ ] video
yeah yeah you too Joe
go ahead I'm just sound know what to say
let's burn them have you guys seen yeah
what's a sentencing is there like is he
like gonna get raped repeatedly in jail
he has to wear that shirt for the rest
[Laughter]
he has to cut hair with swords only
that's it
dude he could never afford that killing
his own son that's crazy man electricity
that might as well be 500 million he
could get out with $5,000 oh is that it
yeah that's still a lot for him when you
know when you hear like bail and all
that you just go to that's why you go to
bail bonds right and then they put up
the money for you pay 10 percent of his
bill he's not gonna get it though
because nobody likes him so nobody's
gonna be
yeah sex-offender baby killer yeah well
you could call the Bell company bail
himself out if he has five thousand he's
going to die well if you can't pay for
the electricity yeah he's he doesn't
have the money for it can you imagine
living in the dark how's your guys
lights went out for like over two days
before yeah dude my AC went out and I
was like I live in the dark ages my AP
went out of my car and I feel terrible
right but I start sleeping earlier when
that happens
[Music]